this could well be the biggest
corruption scandal in modern American
history but according to the ladies of
the view it's a little more than a
heartfelt story this is about a Father's
Love For His Son who's addicted to crack
and hookers take a look
the hunter Biden story
also the story of a Father's Love and
Joe Biden has never and will never give
up on his son son Hunter and will never
treat him lesser than and so he is a
father first take it or leave it that's
who he is that is part of his heart
now too bad Joe doesn't exhibit the same
love for his four-year-old granddaughter
you know the one that he won't even
acknowledge meanwhile fake news CNS has
exclusively apparently obtained another
audio recording used as evidence in
Trump's document case it's kind of weird
because there are virtually no leaks
from Biden's document investigation if
there even really is one it's almost as
if we have a two-tiered system of
justice isn't it well kind of shocking
anyway here with reaction Fox News
contributor Miranda Devine and former
senior advisor to president Trump
Stephen Miller Stephen I'll start with
you in the leak of the tape just like
the leak of every other detail uh to the
media
seemingly from the special counsel but
only Trump's special counsel we haven't
heard a peep out of the so-called
special counsel looking at the bidens
we've seen this for seven long years
Sean where the federal government when
it is persecuting when it is going after
when it is trying to frame president
Trump they selectively leak in order to
manipulate news stories to try to poison
the narrative to try to create a false
impression and they've been doing this
over and over and over and over again
because the security state is very
skilled at psychological warfare they're
skilled at the art and Artistry that's
often deployed in foreign countries of
how to control the narrative in our
country my message to the American
people is don't fall for it we have been
watching them try to play us year after
year after year going all the way back
to the Russia hoax and of course
remember the Ukraine hoax remember in
the election year remember the Russian
Bounty story where Trump was letting
Russia get away with putting bounties on
our troops then it comes out later that
was a fake story and of course we
remember what they did to suppress the
hunter Biden story and now what they are
doing and have been doing doing to
Shield Joe Biden from accountability for
his influence peddling with his son
Hunter
all right let's get your take Miranda
Devine uh you know I tried to lay out
here maybe I don't think I'm overstating
the case that our government is corrupt
that our doj is corrupt it's weaponized
that our FBI at the top especially I'm
not talking about Rank and file I think
a lot of them you know are good people
trying to do a good job and and
unfortunately they don't have the
leadership uh that they frankly deserve
uh to restore that that agency to what
it once was the premier law enforcement
agency in the world your reaction always
you're you're spot on and I think we've
seen the corruption of the doj and the
top echelons of the FBI laid out in
Stark detail on Friday in the testimony
of the two IRS whistleblowers who are
very courageous to have come forward and
I hope that every American has their
back because they are in for a world of
pain as the very expensive lawyers of
Hunter Biden come after them in every
single way they can and as they are
being retaliated against right now by
the federal government to which they
gave more than a Dozen Years each of
their lives these are courageous and
diligent public servants and what they
have done is they have broken ranks and
been
had Integrity like nobody else has it
seems in that investigation that went
for five years into Hunter Biden in
Delaware and they have told chapter and
verse about how they were obstructed and
slow walked every step of the way and
someone is lying because attorney
general Merrick Garland has said flat
out that U.S attorney David Weiss did
not ask to be made a special counsel and
David Weiss told six Witnesses according
to Gary shapley the IRS whistleblower
that he asked the doj if he could be
made special counsel so he could
override the Biden appointed U.S
attorneys in D.C and the Central
District district of California who
refused to allow them to bring charges
against Hunter Biden in their
jurisdictions so someone is lying and I
I believe that the Republicans in the
house will be hauling those people in to
testify under oath
yeah all right let me go back to you
Stephen Miller because this is now
impacting the 2024 election and in a lot
of different ways I mean so you got the
doj protected Hillary in 2016. Donald
Trump was able to win but clearly they
were working against him and they were
even a will they were even willing to
use an uncorroborated frankly
unverifiable or in the words of Durham
they couldn't even prove a single thing
in that dossier nothing and operation
Crossfire hurricane never should have
opened up then pre-bunking the New York
Post story about hunter's laptop the
very real laptop from hell that Miranda
probably knows inside and out better
than anyone in the country and and now
you know now we've got one prosecution
after another after another in one venue
after another after another that's not
favorable to Donald Trump they trying to
do the same thing and put cinder blocks
on the scales of presidential elections
the Deep state in favor of of
Joe Biden again
absolutely and that's exactly what they
are doing putting cinder blocks on the
scales of this election as they have now
in two previous election cycles first by
shielding Hillary Clinton and her pay
for play scheme then by shielding Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden over their
influence peddling scheme and now by
trying to throw Donald Trump into prison
in the middle of the presidential
campaign how much more of this do we
have to witness before we can all arrive
at the obvious conclusion that the
Department of Justice and the security
state are working against our democracy
and against the American people if you
compare the treatment Donald Trump has
gotten one false allegation after
another one investigation after another
his life torrent upside down and torn
apart and you compare that to what we
have seen from these IRS whistleblowers
as Miranda said these courageous
whistleblowers and how the doj has been
over backwards to Shield Joe Biden when
you compare those two things you can
arise but no other conclusion but that
you are right Sean and that the
Department of Justice is corrupt
all right we appreciate your time
Stephen Miller thank you Miranda Devine
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else